if you love streams of baby photos cats
and the color blue you're going to love
the oculus rift interface with the
Facebook interface and logo reportedly
making its way to the virtual reality
hardware according to the New York Times
a source involved in the deal revealed
that Facebook will eventually redesign
the oculus rift hardware to use the
social media platforms logo and
interface the social media company
announced its acquisition of oculus VR
earlier today the buyout is worth an
estimated two billion dollars following
the news oculus rift creator Palmer
Luckey hopped onto the forum reddit to
explain that the buyout will allow
virtual reality to go mainstream
impacting not only gaming but also many
other industries the news was met with a
particularly strong reaction from
minecraft creator notch who proceeded to
cancel development on the oculus rift
version of Minecraft how exactly do you
imagine that interface will look more
Facebook be pushing those targeted ads
for Russian brides but in 3d everyone
gets those ads right anyway take to
photoshop with your best illustrations I
have to know and stick around for more
gamespot news updates